for the angels it's andrew [ __ ] the
lefty from oklahoma state
he's one and three with a 531 earned run
average
the next batter stepping up to the plate
has been their top run producer by far
this season and this is
uh dolis garcia counts owen two and
here's the next delivery
bounces this one out towards short
fielded by iglesias he'll flip to
fletcher they'll force out low and the
inning is over
on the 6-4 fielder's choice so a good
first inning for andrew haney faces four
batters and they
fail to really do much against them here
in the
very first inning of play bottom of the
first coming up for the rangers hyung
john young
will make his third start his sixth
appearance the lefty from korea 01 with
a 338 era
upton 197 batting average
two for his last 16 six for his last 44.
young was a 20-game winner in south
korea in 2017
won a couple of era titles was a
most valuable pitcher in the kbo one
season that's when he had the
big year in 2017. signed a minor league
deal with texas this off season in the
pitch and this one has lifted high
it's hit deep out into left center field
it is
out of here
that is a blast by upton
ninth home run of the season that one
uh headed out to the angels bullpen
where all the
relievers are high fiving each other
someone must have made a catch on that
one angel's on top one nothing here in
the first
and anthony rendon is next back to the
set
a long hold by yong in the pitch to
rendon his line right back at him he
spears it
lobster first and they double off ohtani
so it's a line drive double play
1-3 ohtani hung out to dry nothing he
could do on that
and young grabbing that ball about
shoulder high
just off to his right and
there are two outs now one nothing
angels for juan legaris
and here's the pitch that one is lying
to left field
moving back and leaping and making the
catches willie calhoun just as he
reached the warning track
calhoun spears that one and ends the
inning another hard hit drive off of
yong
they hit three of them pretty hard in
the inning they settle for one run on
one hit
nobody left after one it's one to
nothing angels
david dahl will be the next batter
he has been a strikeout pitcher this
season entered the game with 50 in only
39
innings he's had two starts this year
with 10 strikeouts and here's one lifted
in the air down the right side
diving after it out there in right field
and making the grab
is taylor ward well the
ranger hitters are giving ward a workout
here in the first couple of innings
that's his third put out he has
half of the outs recorded behind genie
and that was
a nice diving catch on that one got that
one just before it hit the ground
jared walsh will be in the next batter
they keep their shortstop isaiah kinder
philetha holm he's
right by the second base bag next
deliveries is lifted high in the air
it's hit deep out into right field out
by the short wall and it's out of here
walsh has homer snuck it over the short
wall
two-run shot is 11th of the season
angels are playing long ball in the
early going now have a three-nothing
lead
dog came very close to an extra base hit
his first time up
but a very nice diving catch by taylor
ward
out toward the right field corner took
care of dahl for the final out that was
back in the second inning
see the rangers they've been good in
these spots 11 for 31 with the bases
loaded
in the dirt and that one gets away and
here comes solac he'll score easily
first run of the ball game on the wild
pitch and it's 3-1
next pitch this is popped up foul behind
the plate should be the end of the
inning and suzuki will go back and make
the grab on that one back near the
backstop
and the inning ends on a foul ball to
the angel's catcher
jared walsh dangerous hitter home run
first time up two run homer for jared
walsh
here's walsh swinging and bouncing one
out of the reach is so lacking through
into
right field that will easily score the
lead runner laguaris
and then iglesias moves over to third on
the rbi
hits a walsh a three rbi game already
he's driven in three of the four angel
runs it's now 4-1
ward is five for his last 26 season
average now at 186.
and he's around about and drops one on
one hop it's fielded by the first
baseman no one's there to cover
no chance to get it out at the plate and
the angels just squeezed in a run right
there it's
5-1 so the batter now is justin upton
angel's lead up man is homered and
struck out he's one for two
tuesday night baseball angels up 5-1
next pitch
bounced on the left side out of the
reach to kind of left for the short stop
that's going to be another run and the
angels will have them
at the corners as upton gets his second
rbi of the night
it's 6-1 angels so hey otani at the
plate with the angels up by
five runs here in inning number four
full count we'll see what gives on the
3-2
here it comes ohtani blast one down the
right side a line
drive and that ball hits off the foul
ball
that is a three-run homer
the lead just keeps growing it's now
9-1 as ohtani hits his
15th of the season and tonight it's
show time here's the glaciers who's had
a pair of walks
here's the next delivery shot into right
center field that is a gapper and that's
going to take a bounce and hit off the
wall
going into third base being waved home
is lagarris
throw to the plate it's late he'll score
and iglesias has an rbi
double third time he's been on base
tonight
it's now 10-1 angels not sure if he
might have
heard something running the bases and
with the game where it is right now at
10-1 i guess they're not going to take
any
chances and taylor ward is
coming up now i want to win the count
and the pitch
that's fisted up in the air to short
right field coming on hard and sliding
is dull and he makes the catch
nice play by david dahl and a little
flare to right
so kurt suzuki the angels
catcher the batter the iglesias jose
iglesias who left with an apparent
hamstring
problem he missed a lot of time last
season but it wasn't a
hamstring injury it was a quad injury
here's a little pop into shallow center
off the bat of suzuki that's gonna drop
in
and that is going to drive in another
angel run
second one in the inning the 11th one in
the game it's now
11-1 halos here in the bottom of the
fifth
and here's garcia over two
oh he did swing and that ball is crushed
deep to left and gone
and garcia has answered with his 15th
home run of the year
a two-run shot in the sixth makes it
11-3
any time when you get a manager comes
out the mountain you want to give the
baseball to the manager
you don't want to give it to the catcher
you want to make sure you give it to the
matter just one rule
dick hauser my first year first time on
the mound
the major league level he said listen no
matter what i know you're going to be
upset here and there
i want that baseball handed to me i
don't want it flipped in the air i want
to hand it to me
with respect and anthony rendon coming
up brendon is
oh for four in the midst of all this the
set
the pitch strike three call rindon is
out and
so are the angels no runs two hits two
left
and counter falafel will be the batter
with solac on deck
the right-hander's set and the pitch is
way inside it gets away from the catcher
suzuki and that will score a run
so uh davis is home it's now an 11-4
angels lead the pitch
is grounded weakly to shore the run will
score
fletcher throws him out at first izzy
picks up his 21st rbi
it's now an 11-5 game one more out to go
solac will be the batter here's the o2
this is a shot in the center field and
making the grab on that one is
laguaris and medium center on that
ball hit low out there and that will
wrap up the ball game so the angels come
away with the
victory here in the opener of this
little two game series